okay well champion is playing  um king f5 bishop d6 95 check  okay if king b6 it's knight c4  why why what's wrong with king c7  king c7 only move and now king is six  okay  that's another way to do it anyway it's  completely winning with two pawns up  and we will see probably the end shake  two player  just shake hands i'm curious actually  because i saw some some funny handshake  between ali  yesterday and his opponent i mean  whereas they didn't know what to do  exactly king e6 will be played  king is six magnus carson will  win his match 2-0 and face iron tie  king e6 it's now it's completely over  maybe you can try bish ah bishop c5  just queen i just queen here  takes check  up coming queening so bishop c5 was  played  i think queen magnus we just play  queen or hook no it's playing 96 which  is  even simpler it's queen next move  resign from martinovich let's see  it's a nice handshake or not